Mike Florio pro football talk live
co-host on NBC Sports Network pro
football talk calm let me start with
that Mike good morning do you think the
NFL has looked at would look at a
lottery for the number one overall pick
I assume Dan and good morning hello
great to be with you as always I think
the FL has at least considered it I
think the NFL won't do it at least they
won't do it in the way the NBA does it
because the NFL wants to preserve the
disconnect currently exists I believe
between the integrity of the game and
every team trying to win every single
game and all the way down to week 17 if
you're one in 15 you're trying to win
that last game and the obvious draft
type that we hear every year of how
great it is to pick high in the draft
and the moment you'll have a draft
lottery that is weighted based upon how
poorly you did the prior year that's the
moment you legitimize tanking and the
NFL just doesn't acknowledge it they say
that's the only way to deal with it act
like it doesn't exist surely it exists
at the highest levels of a team an owner
thinking hey you know what once it was
between three and thirteen and two and
fourteen anyway when I can get a guy
that's going to transform the franchise
so let's bench the starters let's see
what the backups can do we're evaluating
them while also hoping to lose so we can
get that high pick so I don't think the
NFL wants to do it because the NFL
doesn't want to acknowledge tanking
because think about what an event if the
NFL did it right and didn't like
city-to-city like it does with the draft
and played it in one of the cities where
where you know the fan base has a chance
of having the number one overall pick it
would be an incredible offseason event
but I don't think the NFL wants to touch
that one at all I saw this tweet from
Ross Tucker he talked about the Jets
situation the head coach Adam GaSe got
the GM fired alienated the team's best
offensive player Le'Veon Bell became the
only coach with a GM title brought the
circus back to town traded a starting
linebacker for peanut peanuts all within
10 hours that's a heck of a day how do
you spin this if you're a Jets fan or
the Jets organization well I don't know
that there's any way to spin it other
than look he's already in the bar for
the 2019 roster the team is set they're
ready to go there wasn't much that Mike
McKagan was going to do anyway and the
best time to fire a GM is after the
drill
now the problem is if you had an
inclination to fire the guy before the
draft why did you keep them around and
then the question becomes how much juice
did McKagan really have leading up to
the 2019 Draft it could be that as they
got closer and close to the draft
maybe gays had more influences they set
before those are things were never
better no but I'm a big fan of just
ripping the band-aid off in one motion
if you're gonna fire the coach in the
champ fill it together because now
you're going to have either a GM that is
hired by Jason gates and merges if the
guy who's running a franchise or if you
go out and hire somebody with no
connection to gays you get this arranged
marriage like joint if you can Rex Ryan
York where the new GM is biding his time
to when he can fire gays and go hire his
own coach and that's not good for
anybody you so now that they're in this
spot the best move is to let gays hire
the GM and then hope that the two guys
can work together equal accountability
so there's no temptation try to
undermine each other neither both
succeed when they both fail and they
both get fired not one or the other yeah
but you bring in lady on bail and then
all of a sudden bail here is that the
head coach thought that the team over
paid for him I just said play out well
they did overpay for him I think they
were bidding against no one in the
magnitude that they ultimately paid bail
there was a lot of fake stuff out there
about the Ravens being on top 2008 and I
think Gates knew that and he was banging
the drum internally but it never
registered with mckagan which led to the
friction now all case has to do is dial
a bell and say look I know you've seen
some stuff out there I never didn't want
you I just wanted us to do a more
aggressive negotiation when it was time
to try to work this out and
congratulations you and your agent got
more than I thought you should have done
now go out through me wrong and earn
this contract and we're in this together
and our legacies are tied to it and
let's go it's a football games I think
it's something that gates should be able
to fix in five minutes if they'll ever
shows up and I said dak Prescott says
that he knows that the deal will get
done it's no rush I might be in the
minority here I'd like to see one more
year with dak Prescott before I'm gonna
pony up a hundred million dollars Mike
your thoughts on the Cowboys and dak
Prescott
well I think the smart move to the
Cowboys you know because that test I can
talk about waiting Lots and I've seen
players do that and it seems you could
talk about it when there isn't an offer
sitting on the table of life-changing
money but then they also said they put
an offer out there and you look at what
they're offering versus what you're
going to make versus the injury risk you
get carry for another year and I think
there's a way that the Cowboys could put
together a package where they are making
a big but reasonable investment
somewhere in the range of 25 to 28
million per year for deck Prescott not
30 million not Russell Wilson money not
Aaron Rodgers money 25 to 27 with the
understanding the quarterback of the
Dallas Cowboys every time you play on
national TV you're going to draw a
gigantic audience you're going to have
endorsements you're he's already -
Daniel yogurt I hope that Prescott the
Daniel yogurt got you're going to have
more endorsements you know also do a
broadcast booth when his careers over
there's inherent eyes and being
accountable we started quarterback you
throw that on the top of whatever offer
they eventually put on the table and
Prescott looks at that and he looks at
making two million this year with the
injury risk with the risk that maybe
he's not going to have a great year and
I think it's going to be very hard for
him to say no to that any update on the
NFL if there will be punishment for
Robert Kraft well I you know the
criminal proceeding in Florida has to
end before the league will even begin to
look into this and with the ruling from
earlier in the week that the
surveillance video won't be evidence at
trial they'll be appeal of that ruling
by the prosecution that delays the
process the NFL won't do nothing until
that criminal process is over and then
the question becomes Dan whatever the
end result is and right now it's looking
like Robert Kraft is going to be
exonerated
without that video evidence without the
evidence from the traffic stop you can't
prove solicitation of prostitution
beyond a reasonable doubt then the
question becomes you look at the
personal conduct policy line by line
where is the violation if it was a
player
there'd be no punishment if there's
exoneration for solicitation of
prostitution so where is the violation
and how does the league turn that into
punishment of an owner we hear all the
time owners are held to a higher
standard but if it's something a player
wouldn't be punished for at all what's
the higher
standards that that's gonna be the
challenge for me because a lot of people
are going to be saying he must be
punished but if you look at the personal
conduct policy and he's ultimately
exonerated for solicitation of
prostitution
I don't know personal conduct policy
will justify a punishment at all and
that's going to be a mess roger goodell
to have to fix most improved team after
the draft is whoo-hoo I you know I don't
know because we never know how good
these guys be until they get all the
footballs here I kinda like what
Washington's done because I really like
Blaine Haskins and I think if Tyler
Murray had chosen to play football
Haskins would have been the guy we were
talking about it the first overall pick
I think he's much better than he gets
credit for people say he lacks mobility
I mean they just haven't watched any of
his film from college
he's got great mobility in the pocket
and if Montez swept the guy they trade
it back into round one but yet who had a
four or 140 as a defensive lineman if he
doesn't have a heart issue if he isn't
impaired by that he can be a huge impact
right away that's a team that no one's
paying attention to those are always
teams to watch aren't they're the ones
that surprised us
no one's paying attention to them they
come up and start winning games and then
we get on the board with with that team
and then the Patriots win the Super Bowl
guys wait do you think that if Arizona
had the number one pick and Kyler Murray
was playing baseball and they still had
Josh Rosen that they would have drafted
Dwayne Hoskins the guy with the time you
know maybe I don't know you know but I
he'd been the guy we were talking about
top quarterback of the draft and maybe I
don't know but who knows what the hell
the charge you're saying but I think
Haskins is a guy who we've got a lot
more folks you just kind of Forgotten
overlooked in this process after a bowl
game after that performance hey this guy
doesn't look like the number what people
a draft
man here comes kind of version we just
forget about green house thank you Mike
great to talk to you again buddy
take care hi Dan that's Mike Florio Pro
Football Talk live co-host on NBC Sports
Network and pro football talk to comm
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]